digamos que piensas frecuentemente en la
compañía abc de y estás convencido de
que el precio de sus acciones subirán
donde su precio de cotización actual es
de 50 pesos de 50 pesos y podrías hacer
dos cosas
podrías primero comprar la acción por 50
pesos y esperar a que el precio suba o
ya aquí yo puse este precio el cual su
vídeo o podrías ir al mercado y por
cinco pesos podrías comprar la opción
para comprar la acción el mes siguiente
pues sería el próximo mes ya que
usualmente las opciones tienen una fecha
específica pero bueno yo estoy diciendo
que es un mes a partir del momento en
que la compraste y te dará la opción de
comprar las acciones por 60 pesos cada o
cada acción y el tipo de opción que
estoy describiendo es llamada la opción
de compra americana la cual podemos
comparar con la europea sin embargo esta
la podemos ejercer en todo momento a
cambio la opción europea la puedes
ejercer solamente a la expiración y bien
vamos a enfocarnos en la opción
americana
ahora vamos a ver los resultados que
vienen dependiendo de lo que haga la
acción así que digamos que la acción va
a ser exactamente lo que tú crees que va
a pasar
digamos que sabes que luego luego va a
bajar y digamos que él es realmente
bueno hacer tándem que precios va a
tener la acción cuando suben y cuando
bajan por lo que compraste a 50 pesos y
luego por aquí te fuiste al máximo donde
podríamos decir que es 80 pesos y donde
tú eres una persona que realmente acerca
de qué tipo de altos y bajos va a tener
la acción así que vamos a pensar en los
distintos escenarios para las ganancias
bien por aquí tenemos un precio final de
80 pesos por acción y si tú me compraste
la acción por 50 pesos y ahora la vendes
en 80 vas a tener una ganancia de 30
pesos y ahora pensemos que en lugar de
comprar las acciones compras la opción
hoy así que si compras la opción es lo
mismo cuando las acciones suben vas a
decir oh yo pienso que el máximo de la
acción va a ser esto entonces
ejercerla así que vamos a ejercer la
opción la cual me da el derecho de
comprar las acciones en 60 pesos cada
una entonces vas a comprar las acciones
por 60 pesos por acción y luego puedes
inmediatamente venderla a 80 cada acción
por lo que generaría 20 pesos con esta
transacción pero por supuesto no olvides
que pagaste 5 pesos por dicha opción así
que en total generas de 15 pesos netos
ahora tú dirías mira tal vez sea mejor
comprar simplemente las acciones y esto
es cierto para este caso pero yo te
diría al comprar las acciones únicamente
tienes que poner 50 pesos de capital
pero todos están en riesgo y al comprar
la opción tendrías que poner 5 pesos
únicamente en riesgo y para ver esto
vamos a imaginarnos el escenario
negativo donde en lugar de que la acción
haga esto vamos a decir que va a bajar y
que llega a caer hasta los 20 pesos
ahora la situación con las acciones
digamos que justo aquí tuviste
suficiente y vas a perder entonces de
tus 50 pesos 30
en el escenario de la opción todo eso
que se está desplomando pues decir no
quiero ejercer mi opción y simplemente
este dinero no os hace sentido para
perder únicamente cinco pesos que fue lo
que te costó la opción